Come on, Katie! Time to brush our teeth before we go to bed.
Why do I have to brush my teeth?
You need to brush your teeth to keep them clean and healthy.
Why?
When you eat, food can get stuck between your teeth.
Is that bad?
Well, it can make your teeth go bad.
And then they fall out!
Hmm... like the way your teeth fell out?
Well, my teeth fell out, well, my baby teeth, everybody loses their baby teeth when they're growing up.
And then they get more teeth, like you did.
Yes! You get grown-up teeth.
But they have to last forever.
You don't get any more.
Oh, how can I stop my teeth from going bad?
Well, when you brush your teeth you can clean away all bits of food that might be stuck between them.
Like this?
Yes.
Make sure you clean all your teeth even the ones at the back...
...and don't forget your gums.
What are gums?
Your gums hold your teeth onto your mouth so it's really important to look after them too.
I think all my teeth are clean now, look.
They're very clean.
Keep brushing your teeth every day...
...and you'll be able to keep that lovely, shiny white smile.